OK, here's a weird fact that one of the reporters that we work with around here stumbled upon. There are these little pockets all over the country where like 20%, 25% of the people in a given county are on disability. They get government checks for disability.
好的，这有一个奇怪的事实，是我们这里合作的一位记者偶然发现的。在全国各地都有一些小区域，比如某个县里20%到25%的人都在领取残疾补助。他们靠政府发放的残疾救济金生活。
For example, Hale County, Alabama. Nearly one in four working age people are not working, because they're disabled. One in four. What is going on there? Well, last fall, this reporter, Chana Joffe-Walt, who's with Planet Money, she went to Hale county to try to figure out what was going on there. And her experience there was the beginning of a six-month-long obsession with our nation's disability programs. Hey there, Chana.
例如，阿拉巴马州的海尔县（Hale County）。几乎每四个劳动年龄人口中就有一个不工作，因为他们残疾了。四分之一。那里到底发生了什么？去年秋天，Planet Money 的记者查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）前往海尔县，试图弄清楚那里发生了什么。她在那里经历的一切，开启了我们对国家残疾项目长达六个月的钻研。嘿，查娜。
Hello.
你好。
So these are government checks going out every month to a fourth of the population of this county.
所以，政府每个月都要向这个县四分之一的人口发放救济金。
Of this county and other counties. There are other counties and towns like this. And the disability programs that are run by Social Security, if you could prove to the Social Security Administration that your disability prevents you from holding down a job, the government will pay you money. The average people get is about $1,000 a month. And the government also covers your health care.
不仅是这个县，还有其他县。还有其他像这样的县和城镇。社会保障局负责运营残疾项目，如果你能向社会保障局证明你的残疾使你无法维持一份工作，政府就会给你钱。人们平均每月获得约1000美元。政府还会为你承担医疗费用。
Oh, they cover your health care?
哦，他们承担你的医疗费用？
They cover your health care benefits, yeah.
是的，他们承担你的医疗福利。
I didn't realize that.
我没意识到这一点。
Yeah, and in Hale County, people have all kinds of theories why this might be. Why one in four adults are on disability.
是的，在海尔县，人们对于为什么会这样有各种各样的理论。为什么四个成年人中就有一个在领取残疾补助？
And are freeloaders on the list? Is that it?
名单上都是些爱占便宜的人吗？是这样吗？
Freeloaders, fakers, people who are faking disability was always the number one theory.
爱占便宜的人、骗子，那些伪装残疾的人，这始终是第一大理论。
Oh I don't know. Don't get talking to me on that. But hey, there's people on disability in this town that I can write a list out is able as much to work as I am. It's going to ruin the country.
哦，我不知道。别跟我说这个。但是，嘿，这个镇上有些人领着残疾补助，我可以列出一份名单，他们跟我一样有能力工作。这会毁了这个国家。
This is John Jay. He's a fit guy in his 70s. I met him in Greensboro, the county seat in Hale County. And John Jay is the head of the utilities board in Greensboro. He used to be the mayor. He sits on the board of a local bank. Basically, a guy who is used to people listening to him. And he has some theories he wanted to share.
这是约翰·杰伊（John Jay）。他是一位70多岁、身体硬朗的男士。我在海尔县的县治格林斯伯勒（Greensboro）见到了他。约翰·杰伊是格林斯伯勒公用事业委员会的负责人。他曾担任过市长。他还在当地一家银行的董事会任职。基本上，他是一个习惯于别人听他指挥的人。他有一些想分享的理论。
Is it OK with   you that I'm  recording? I'm doing a story  for the radio.
你介意我录音吗？我正在为电台做一个报道。
You just have anything you want, I  say. Because I'll tell anybody to the world. I'll get out there in front of the thing. But doctors, oh, whoa, my shoulder hurts and my knee hurts, doctor. I just can't work no more. Can you get me on disability? And they keep going back and back, and they'll put him on disability. And then nobody comes checks them.
你想怎么样都行，我说过。因为我会告诉全世界任何人。我会站出来面对这一切。但是医生，哦，哇，我的肩膀疼，我的膝盖疼，医生。我再也干不动了。你能帮我申请残疾补助吗？他们不断地回去复诊，然后他们就会被列入残疾名单。之后就没人来检查他们了。
OK, so fakers is one theory.
好的，所以“骗子”是一种理论。
So fakers is one theory. But there were actually lots of theories. I sat in on dozens of conversations like this where people were just trying to explain the high numbers to themselves. For instance, a group of ministers I met in a coffee shop were sitting around wondering if it was because of the food. It's very hard to find healthy food in Hale County. There's lots of obesity.
所以“骗子”是一种理论。但实际上有很多理论。我旁听了数十场这样的对话，人们只是试图向自己解释这些高数字的原因。例如，我在咖啡店遇到的一群牧师正坐在一起琢磨，是不是因为饮食的原因。在海尔县很难找到健康的食物。那里有很多肥胖症。
I heard there's something in the water in Hale County. I sat with one couple on beach chairs on their porch, and the wife, [INAUDIBLE] said, it could be because people here just live life full force. But as she was talking, her husband, Cecil, was shaking his head
我听说海尔县的水里有什么东西。我和一对坐在门廊沙滩椅上的夫妇坐在一起，妻子（名字听不清）说，可能是因为这里的人生活得太“用力”了。但当她说话时，她的丈夫塞西尔（Cecil）一直在摇头。
Like I said, we was always hard playing, hardworking.
就像我说的，我们总是玩得刻苦，工作得刻苦。
I  don't know what that's got to do with the thing.
我不知道这跟那件事有什么关系。
Well, we did things to our bodies that we shouldn't have done. Drinking, smoking.
好吧，我们做了些不该对身体做的事。喝酒、抽烟。
You think people in Hale County just drank and smoked, nobody else did?
你觉得海尔县的人只是喝酒抽烟，而没别人这么做吗？
No, but my age group.
不，但我是说我这个年龄段的人。
Then what's the difference?
那有什么区别？
Look, you've got heart trouble.
你看，你有心脏病。
So I drank and smoked too.
所以我也喝酒抽烟了。
Yeah. I was just saying how we lived. That's--
是的。我只是在说我们过去的生活方式。那是——
Same everywhere else.
到处都一样。
People do smoke in Hale County. There is lots of obesity in Hale County. I think there are definitely people who are faking a disability. But the reality is much more complicated. One in four people in Hale County are disabled because of this much bigger story happening in our country overall.
海尔县的人确实抽烟。海尔县确实有很多肥胖症。我认为确实有人在伪装残疾。但现实要复杂得多。海尔县四分之一的人口被认定为残疾，是因为我们整个国家正在发生一个更大的故事。
And that's why six months later you're still talking about disability programs.
这就是为什么六个月后你还在谈论残疾项目。
It is. Because I feel like what I figured out is that these numbers and the growth of disability programs overall tells a story about the economy that's very different from the one we usually hear.
正是。因为我觉得我发现的是，这些数字和残疾项目的整体增长，讲述了一个关于经济的故事，这与我们通常听到的截然不同。
Run me through the numbers.
给我梳理一下这些数字。
OK, so the growth numbers are pretty staggering. Some of this is the Baby Boomer generation. As they age, more and more of them qualify as disabled.
好的，增长数字非常惊人。其中一部分是“婴儿潮”一代。随着他们变老，他们中越来越多的人符合残疾资格。
Because, basically when any generation gets older, they get more disabled.
因为基本上，任何一代人变老，他们就变得越残疾。
Exactly. But Baby Boomers is a big generation. Still, it doesn't explain all the growth. Today there are 14 million Americans receiving payments for a disability.
没错。但婴儿潮一代是一个庞大的群体。尽管如此，这并不能解释所有的增长。今天，有1400万美国人正在领取残疾补助。
And how fast is this growing?
这个增长速度有多快？
Fast. The number of workers on disability has basically been doubling every 15 years. And part of what's surprising about that is that it's happened despite all these other factors that you'd think would have exactly the opposite effect.
很快。领取残疾补助的劳动者人数基本上每15年翻一番。令人惊讶的一部分是，尽管有所有其他你认为会产生完全相反效果的因素，这种情况还是发生了。
That would take people off of disability.
那本会减少残疾补助人数。
Right. And that would drive the numbers down. For instance, the Americans with Disabilities Act. Remember, that's supposed to ban discrimination against people with disabilities. So you would think, in theory, that more disabled people would be working because of that.
对。那本会压低数字。例如，《美国残疾人法案》。记住，那本该是禁止歧视残疾人的。所以从理论上讲，你会认为更多的残疾人会因此去工作。
But during this period, the numbers grew?
但在那段时期，数字反而增长了？
But during that period, the numbers grew. In the 1990s, unemployment declined, crime declined, welfare was down, the economy was doing great.
在那段时期，数字增长了。20世纪90年代，失业率下降，犯罪率下降，福利减少，经济表现良好。
And the numbers still grew?
数字还在增长？
And the numbers grew during the 1990s. And there are so many more services available to people who have disabilities. We have perfected artificial hips and knees to help people walk. And we have better hearing aids to help people hear. And computer programs that read for blind people from their computers.
90年代数字一直在增长。而且残疾人可以获得的服务也多了很多。我们完善了人工髋关节和膝关节来帮助人们行走。我们有更好的助听器来帮助人们听见声音。还有为盲人阅读电脑内容的计算机程序。
And as all this is coming in, the disability numbers still grow.
随着这一切的到来，残疾数字仍在增长。
The disability numbers have still been growing and growing and growing.
残疾数字一直在增长、增长、再增长。
And we have barely paid attention to this. The number of disabled workers is not reported alongside unemployment data or welfare numbers or jobs numbers.
而且我们几乎没有注意到这一点。残疾劳动者的数量并没有与失业数据、福利数据或就业数据一起公布。
Oh, that's right. You never hear these numbers on the news.
哦，那是真的。你在新闻里从来没听过这些数字。
Never. So it's basically 14 million people who do not show up in any of the places that we look to to explain how things are going, to tell us how our economy is doing. And the jobs numbers, that's the thing that we pay a lot of attention to right now. The monthly disability numbers are just as big.
从来没有。所以基本上有1400万人，他们没有出现在我们用来解释经济状况的任何指标中。而就业数字是我们现在非常关注的。每月的残疾人数其实和就业数据一样庞大。
Since the economy began its slow, slow recovery in late 2009, we have been averaging about 150,000 jobs created per month. In that same period every month, almost 250,000 people have been applying for disability.
自2009年底经济开始缓慢复苏以来，平均每月创造的就业岗位约有15万个。而在同一时期，每个月几乎有25万人申请残疾补助。
Wait, wait, wait. It's 150,000 new jobs created every month, and it's 250,000 people applying for disability every month?
等等，等等。每个月创造15万个新就业岗位，而每个月有25万人申请残疾补助？
Right.  Every month 250,000 people want to be on the disability programs.
对。每个月有25万人想要加入残疾项目。
OK, so you're saying this massive change  has been unfolding for 30 years, right? It's millions of people, hundreds of billions of dollars?
好的，所以你是说这种巨大的变化已经发生了30年了，对吧？涉及数百万人，数千亿美元？
Hundreds of billions, indeed.
确实是数千亿美元。
Most of us have no idea that this is happening. And so today on our program, we're going to look at why these numbers are ballooning, why so many people are going on to disability. I have to say, this is a view of the country that upends a lot of the stories that we tell ourselves about the economy, that we hear about the economy.
我们大多数人根本不知道发生了这种事。所以今天在我们的节目中，我们将看看为什么这些数字在膨胀，为什么这么多人去申请残疾补助。我必须说，这是一个颠覆了我们关于经济的许多叙事的国家视角。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us for this hour. Chana Joffe-Walt has been trying to figure this out for a half of a year. She will be our guide. Here she is.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请留在我们的节目中。查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）半年来一直试图弄清楚这一点。她将作为我们的向导。她来了。
Hale County, Alabama is a place where people have nicknames. Where people tell you whether the man they just mentioned is white or black before they tell you his last name. And it's a  place so deeply shaped by the fact that one in four adults are disabled. That fact explains daily life in town. It's why the banks are open late on the first and  the third of the month, when the disability checks come in. It's why it's hard to find a parking spot on Main Street that entire week, and grocery carts are always full to the brim.
阿拉巴马州的海尔县是一个人们有绰号的地方。是一个在你提到某人姓氏之前，会先告诉你这人是白人还是黑人的地方。这个地方被一个事实深深地塑造着：四分之一的成年人是残疾人。这个事实解释了镇上的日常生活。这就是为什么每个月1号和3号，当残疾支票寄到时，银行会营业到很晚。这就是为什么那一整周你在主街上很难找到停车位，杂货店的购物车总是装得满满的。
Pam Dorr moved to Hale County 10 years ago. And she didn't know the disability numbers when she arrived. So she spent her first year so totally confused about the local economy.
帕姆·多尔（Pam Dorr）10年前搬到了海尔县。她刚到时不知道这些残疾数字。所以她第一年对当地经济感到非常困惑。
Well, I love yard sales, and I'm such a crazy yard saler. But I'd be on my bike the third weekend of the month or the fourth weekend of the month, and there'd be no yard sales. I'd be like really? What's going on? And then I'd notice the first of the month, every place in town had a yard sale. So it just took me a while to understand why.
我喜欢庭院甩卖，我是一个疯狂的甩卖迷。但我骑车经过时，在每月的第三个或第四个周末，根本没有甩卖。我会想，真的吗？怎么回事？后来我注意到在月初，镇上的每个地方都在甩卖。所以花了我一段时间才明白原因。
If you live in Hale County, and you've got an old TV or armchair you're looking to sell, you put it out when you know the neighbors have money to spend.
如果你住在海尔县，手里有旧电视或扶手椅要卖，你会选在邻居们手头有钱的时候摆出来。
A retired judge in town, Sonny Ryan, told me here is what Hale County's got-- lawyers and trees. One gets you  your disability, the other keeps you breathing. Judge Ryan's court didn't hear disability cases. But he says it came up all the time anyway.
镇上的一位退休法官桑尼·瑞安（Sonny Ryan）告诉我，海尔县有什么——律师和树。前者帮你拿到残疾补助，后者让你呼吸。瑞安法官的法庭不审理残疾案件。但他表示这事儿总是会被提起来。
When they would come to court, I'd say, where do you work? I'm on disability. I'd just shake my head, and I would say sometimes to the clerk, I wonder what his disability is, because he doesn't look like he's disabled to me.
当他们来法庭时，我会问：你在哪工作？“我领残疾补助。”我只能摇头。有时我会对书记员说，我不知道他的残疾是什么，因为他看起来不像残疾人。
When you live in a place where disability is so common, the question inevitably arises, how come I'm working, and you're not?
当你住在一个残疾如此普遍的地方，问题不可避免地会出现：为什么我在工作，而你却不工作？
I remember I had one guy in court one day.  And I mean he was robust looking. And I said, just out of curiosity, what is your disability? I have high blood pressure. I said, so do I. I said, what else? He says, I have diabetes. I said, so do I. What else?
我记得有一天法庭上有一个人。我的意思是，他看起来非常强壮。我问他：“出于好奇，你的残疾是什么？”“我有高血压。”我说：“我也有。”我又问：“还有什么？”他说：“我有糖尿病。”我说：“我也有。还有什么？”
The reason this question can come up at all is that disability is basically a made up concept. There's no diagnosis called disability. There's not a blood test you can take. You don't go to the doctor and the doctor says, well, we've run the tests, and it looks like you have disability.
这个问题之所以会出现，是因为“残疾”基本上是一个虚构的概念。没有一种诊断叫“残疾”。也没有血液检查可以做。你去看医生，医生不会说：“好吧，我们做了检查，看起来你有残疾。”
It is, by definition, squishy. Squishy enough that you can end up with one person with high blood pressure who's labeled disabled and another who's labeled judge.
定义上，它是“模糊”的。模糊到你可以看到一个人因为高血压被贴上残疾标签，而另一个人却成了法官。
When it comes down to it, all disability is is  the label we as a society give to people who, when we hear their story, we decide they've suffered enough, and it's not fair to make them work anymore.
说到底，所谓的残疾只是我们作为一个社会给那些人贴上的标签：当我们听到他们的故事时，我们觉得他们已经受够了，再让他们工作是不公平的。
I was in a 1990 Jeep Cherokee Laredo. I flipped it both ways. Flew 165 feet from the Jeep, going through 12,000 to 14,000 volts of electrical lines. Then I landed into a briar patch.
我当时开着一辆1990年的吉普切诺基拉雷多。我把它翻了个底朝天。从车里飞出165英尺，穿过了12000到14000伏的电线。然后掉进了灌木丛里。
This is Dane Mitchell. He's a 23-year-old in a Greensboro coffee shop. And you just feel like, meeting him, OK buddy, you have earned it. And he's not even done.
这是戴恩·米切尔（Dane Mitchell）。他是一位在格林斯伯勒咖啡店里的23岁小伙。见到他时，你会觉得，好吧伙计，你是应得的。而且他还没说完。
I broke all five of my right toes, my right hip, 7 of my vertebrae, shattering one, breaking a right rib, punctured my lung, and then I cracked my neck. So I'm on disability for that very reason.
我摔断了右脚的五个脚趾，右髋关节，7块椎骨碎了一块，断了一根右肋骨，刺穿了肺，还扭伤了脖子。所以我正是因为这个原因在领残疾补助。
I talked to person after person on disability in Hale County. And there were plenty of stories like this, where it's like if anyone deserves disability, it is this person in front of me.
我在海尔县采访了一个又一个领残疾补助的人。有很多这样的故事，你会觉得如果有人应该得到补助，那一定就是眼前这个人。
But there was a range. There were definitely stories where it just didn't seem that clear. It seemed bad, but maybe not bad enough? It was hard to tell.
但也有各种情况。确实有一些故事听起来没那么清楚。看起来情况很糟糕，但也许没那么糟？很难说。
A car hit us from behind. I felt it right then. I got about five herniated discs in my back. So that's what disabled me, the herniated disc in my back. And that was the end of my work.
一辆车从后面撞了我们。我当时就感觉到了。我的背部有大约5个椎间盘突出。所以这就是让我残疾的原因，背部椎间盘突出。那是我工作的终点。
I sat with lots and lots of women in Hale County who told me how their backs kept them up a night. Made it hard for them to stand on the job, to lift children, to lift the elderly.
我在海尔县与许多女性坐下来交谈，她们告诉我背痛是如何让她们彻夜难眠的。让她们在工作中站立、抱孩子、抱老人变得困难。
I used to cry to try to work. It was so painful.
我以前经常边哭边尝试工作。太痛苦了。
You would cry on the way to work?
你在去工作的路上会哭吗？
I would cry at work. I was hurting so bad, I would cry. Because they didn't allow us to sit down. Our job was to stand.
我在工作时会哭。我疼得太厉害了，我会哭。因为他们不允许我们坐下。我们的工作要求站着。
I met people who filleted fish at the fish plant with shoulder injuries, had asthma attacks, diabetes, and lots of back pain. Back pain is everywhere. The number of people suffering from disabling back pain in Alabama doubled in 10 years.
我遇到过在鱼类加工厂切鱼、患有哮喘发作、糖尿病和严重背痛的人。背痛随处可见。阿拉巴马州因背痛而致残的人数在10年内翻了一番。
But it's confusing. I have back pain. My editor has a herniated disc, and he works harder than anyone I know. So who gets to decide this? Who decides if the story, the condition, is bad enough? Who makes that determination?
但这很令人困惑。我也背痛。我的编辑有椎间盘突出，他工作比谁都努力。那么谁有权决定这个？谁来决定这个故事、这种状况是否严重到足以残疾？谁做出这个判定？
Well, in Hale County, it basically seems like there's one guy, a man whose name was mentioned in almost every story people told me about becoming disabled, Dr. Perry Timberlake.
好吧，在海尔县，基本上似乎有一个人，一个名字在人们告诉我关于变得残疾的几乎每个故事中都被提到的人：佩里·廷伯莱克（Dr. Perry Timberlake）医生。
He saw Dr. Timberlake, and Dr. Timberlake sent him right on to a heart doctor.
他看了廷伯莱克医生，廷伯莱克医生直接把他转给了心脏科医生。
Dr. Perry Timberlake. He suggested I apply for my disability.
佩里·廷伯莱克医生。他建议我申请残疾补助。
Who was that who recommended it?
是谁推荐的？
Dr. Timberlake from here.
这儿的廷伯莱克医生。
I became very curious about Dr. Timberlake. And I began to wonder if he was the reason for the one in four. That  could explain it, right? There's one doctor in town, and he's running some sort of disability scam, referring every person he sees to the program.
我对廷伯莱克医生变得非常好奇。我开始怀疑他是否就是那“四分之一”人口的原因。这能解释通，对吧？镇上只有一位医生，他在搞某种残疾骗局，把每个他见的人都转介到这个项目。
And here is what I knew about Dr. Timberlake. He's the only general practitioner in Greensboro. He dodged me and my request for an interview. And he spent some time abroad. Nobody could tell me why.
关于廷伯莱克医生我知道的是这些：他是格林斯伯勒唯一的全科医生。他躲着我和我的采访请求。而且他在国外待了一段时间。没人能告诉我原因。
And then after sitting in his clinic waiting room several mornings in a row, Dr. Timberlake finally agreed to see me. In the first two minutes, he explained his international travels.
然后，在连续几个早晨坐在他的候诊室后，廷伯莱克医生终于同意接见我。在前两分钟，他解释了他的国际旅行。
I started a project in Africa, and I ran out of money. So I came back to work.
我在非洲发起了一个项目，但我没钱了。所以我回来工作了。
Where were you in Africa?
你在非洲哪里？
Uganda. We give people-- help them get mosquito nets.
乌干达。我们给人们——帮助他们获得蚊帐。
There's absolutely nothing shifty about Dr. Timberlake. He is a doctor willing to move permanently to Hale County and serve the rural population. I was told he's one of only a few white people in town who chooses to live in a black neighborhood. Dr. Perry Timberlake, it turns out, is your classic bleeding heart. A doctor in a very poor place, where pretty much every person comes into his office to tell him they are in pain, usually back pain.
廷伯莱克医生绝对没有什么可疑的。他是一位愿意永久搬到海尔县服务农村人口的医生。有人告诉我，他是镇上为数不多的选择住在黑人社区的白人之一。佩里·廷伯莱克医生，原来是一位典型的“多愁善感的人”。他是在一个非常贫穷的地方行医，几乎每个走进他办公室的人都来告诉他他们很痛苦，通常是背痛。
Well, we talk about the pain and what it's like. Does it move in your legs? And I always ask them what grade did you finish.
好吧，我们谈谈疼痛以及它是什么样的。它会移动到你的腿上吗？我总是问他们你读到几年级。
What grade did you finish is not a medical question. But Dr. Timberlake feels this is information he needs to now.
“你读到几年级”不是一个医学问题。但廷伯莱克医生觉得这是他需要知道的信息。
And rarely, rarely-- I'm not sure if ever-- they've said, well, I've finished college, four years. A lot of them have finished the 12th grade. But a lot of them have finished less than that. And just a high school education and not too many sit down jobs with that. I  don't care how smart you are. You just don't get the chance.
很少，很少——我不确定是否曾经有过——他们会说，好吧，我读完了大学，四年。他们中的很多人读完了12年级。但很多人读得更少。仅仅是高中教育，而且没有太多坐着的工作。我不在乎你有多聪明。你就是没有机会。
So you think about that when you think about whether or not somebody is going to benefit from disability?
所以当你考虑某人是否会从残疾补助中受益时，你会想到这一点？
Yeah, yeah, right.
是的，是的，没错。
He's asking about their education, because what the disability paperwork asks about is a patient's ability to function. And the way Dr. Timberlake sees it, with little education and poor job prospects, his patients can't function. So he fills out the paperwork for them.
他询问他们的教育背景，因为残疾文书询问的是病人的功能能力。在廷伯莱克医生看来，教育程度低、就业前景差，他的病人就无法正常工作。所以他替他们填写了文书。
Well, on the exam, I say what I see and what turned out. And then I say they're completely disabled to do gainful work, gainful way you earn money, now or in the future. Now could they eventually get a sit down job? Is that possible? Yeah, but it's very, very unlikely.
嗯，在检查中，我说我看到的和结果。然后我说他们完全无法从事有报酬的工作，现在或将来都不能。现在他们最终能找到坐着的工作吗？有可能吗？是的，但可能性非常、非常小。
Dr. Timberlake is saying one in four people in Hale County are disabled, not because they eat bad food or party too hard or because they're cheating. He's basically saying one in four people should be classified as disabled because they can't get a job. A fact that doesn't really seem like it should be taken into account at all. You're either disabled or you're not.
廷伯莱克医生认为海尔县四分之一的人是残疾人，不是因为他们吃得不好，也不是因为他们玩得太疯狂，也不是因为他们在作弊。他基本上是在说，四分之一的人应该被归类为残疾人，因为他们找不到工作。这个事实似乎根本不应该被考虑在内。你要么残疾，要么不残疾。
But the more I talked to people in Hale County, the more I wondered how important a person's education or job skills really were when it came to a disability. Because of this interaction I kept having over and over again, I'd listen to someone's story of how back pain meant they could no longer work or a shoulder injury had put them out of a job.
但我与海尔县的人谈得越多，就越怀疑一个人的教育或工作技能在残疾问题上到底有多重要。因为我不断地进行这样的互动：我听着关于背痛如何意味着他们再也无法工作，或者肩部受伤如何让他们失业的故事。
And when I said things like, what about a job where you don't have to lift people, or a job where you don't have to use your shoulder or where you don't have to stand all night long, or just simply, have you thought about other jobs that you could do, people gave me such bewildered looks. It was as if I was asking well, how come you   didn't consider becoming an astronaut.
当我说“那不需要搬运的工作呢，或者不需要使用你的肩膀，或者不需要整夜站立的工作呢，或者简单地说，你有没有考虑过你能做的其他工作？”人们给了我那种困惑的眼神。就好像我在问“好吧，你为什么没考虑成为一名宇航员？”
So by the time I was sitting with Ethel Thomas, I had had this conversation with so many people, that after hearing about her work at the fish plant and then as a nurse's aid until she got disability for back pain, I tried to ask the question in a different way.
所以当我和埃塞尔·托马斯（Ethel Thomas）坐在一起时，我已经和这么多人进行过同样的对话。在听了她在鱼类加工厂的工作，以及后来作为护士助理的工作，直到因为背痛获得残疾补助后，我试图换一种方式提问。
In your dream world, if you could have a different job that you could do with your back, what would that be? You're shaking your head.
在你的梦想世界里，如果你能有一份你能带着背伤做的不同工作，那会是什么？你在摇头。
Mmm. I hadn't really thought about it.
嗯。我没怎么想过。
Ethel and I talked for another long while, about the town, her church. I met her husband Joseph, who's also on disability, who has nerve damage in his hands. A good 45 minutes passed. And I was getting ready to leave. And Ethel stopped me.
我和埃塞尔谈了很久，谈到镇上、她的教堂。我见到了她的丈夫约瑟夫（Joseph），他也领着残疾补助，他的手部有神经损伤。大约45分钟过去了。我准备离开。埃塞尔叫住了我。
You asked me a while back what would be the perfect job. I thought about it, and I  said that the perfect job, it would be like I would sit at a desk like the Social Security people, and just weed out all the ones that come in and file for disability.
你前阵子问我什么是最完美的工作。我想过了，我说最完美的工作就是像社保局的人那样坐在办公桌前，筛选掉那些所有进来申请残疾补助的人。
Wait, so what's your perfect job?
等等，所以你最完美的工作是什么？
I could sit and weed out all the ones that don't need it.
我可以坐着，筛掉所有那些不需要的人。
At first, I thought Ethel's dream job was to be the lady at Social Security, because she thought she'd be good at weeding out the cheaters. But no. After a confusing back and forth, it turned out Ethel wanted this woman's job because she gets to sit. That's it. And when I asked her, OK, but why that lady? Why not any other job where you get to sit? Ethel said she could not think of a single other job where you get to sit all day. She said she'd never seen one.
起初，我以为埃塞尔的梦想工作是成为社保局的那位女士，因为她觉得她会很擅长把骗子剔除。但不是。在一场令人困惑的对话后，结果是埃塞尔想要那个女人的工作，因为她可以坐着。仅此而已。当我问她“好吧，但为什么是那个女人？为什么不是其他可以坐着的工作？”埃塞尔说她想不出还有什么工作可以整天坐着。她说她从未见过一个。
I brushed this off in the moment. I was getting in my car. It was getting late. And also, it just did not seem possible to me that there would be a place in America today where someone could go her whole working life without any exposure to jobs where you get to sit, until she applied for disability and saw a woman who gets to sit all day. There had to be an office or storefront in town where Ethel would have seen a job that's not physical.
我当时没在意。我正要上车。天色晚了。而且，我实在无法相信在美国今天还会有一个地方，有人能在整个工作生涯中从未接触过可以坐着的工作，直到她申请了残疾补助，看到一个整天可以坐着的女人。镇上肯定有一间办公室或店面，埃塞尔本应该看到过非体力劳动的岗位。
And I started sort of casually looking. At McDonald's, they're all standing. There's a truck mechanic, no. A  fish plant, definitely no. I looked at the jobs listings in  Greensboro-- occupational therapist, McDonald's, McDonald's, truck driver heavy lifting, KFC, registered nurse, McDonald's. I actually think it might be possible that Ethel could not conceive of a job that would accommodate her pain.
我开始随便找了找。在麦当劳，他们都站着。卡车修理工，不行。鱼类加工厂，绝对不行。我看了一下格林斯伯勒的招聘启事——职业治疗师、麦当劳、麦当劳、需要重体力的卡车司机、肯德基、注册护士、麦当劳。我真的认为很有可能埃塞尔根本无法想象出一份能容纳她病痛的工作。
It is that gap between the world I live in and Ethel's world that's a big part of why the disability program has been growing so rapidly. A gap that prevents someone from even imagining the working world I live in, where there are jobs where you can work and have a sore back, or, in her husband Joseph's case, damaged nerves in his hands.
我生活的世界和埃塞尔的世界之间的那道鸿沟，是残疾项目增长如此迅速的重要原因。这道鸿沟阻碍了人们去想象我所生活的世界，在那里，有一些工作是你可以在背部酸痛时去做的，或者，在她丈夫约瑟夫的情况下，手部有神经损伤时也能做的。
Did you try to look for jobs that didn't involve your hands?
你有没有试着找过不需要用手的工作？
What would you do? What kind of work could you do without your hands?
你能做什么？你不用手能做什么样的工作？
I don't know. What could I do? I don't think mashing grapes is going to work here. We don't do that kind of stuff here.
我不知道。我能做什么？我不认为在这里踩葡萄能行。我们这里不干那种事。
Mashing grapes with your feet.
用脚踩葡萄。
With your feet. So we don't do that here. So that's probably all I could have done. So I don't  think I know. Every job I ever be in my life,  I  had to use my hands to do it.
用脚。所以我们这里不干那个。所以我可能只能做那个了。所以我不认为我知道。我这辈子做的每一份工作，都必须用手来做。
Joseph and Ethel Thomas live in a depressed town in a poor state in a national economy that is basically in the process of fully abandoning every kind of job they know how to do. Being poorly educated in a rotten place, that in and of itself has become a disability.
约瑟夫和埃塞尔·托马斯生活在一个贫穷州的一个萧条城镇里，在这个国家的经济中，他们知道如何做的每一种工作基本上都在被完全抛弃。在一个烂地方接受过低教育，这本身就成了残疾。
This is a new reality. This gap between workers who are fit for the US economy and millions of workers who are increasingly not. And it's a change that's spreading to towns and cities that have thrived in the American economy. Places that made cars and steel and batteries and textiles.
这是一个新的现实。这道鸿沟存在于适合美国经济的劳动者与数百万日益不适合的劳动者之间。这种变化正在蔓延到那些曾经在美国经济中繁荣的城镇和城市。那些曾经制造汽车、钢铁、电池和纺织品的地方。
The disability programs are acting like a sponge, sopping up otherwise desperate people. This is happening so often in so many parts of the country, this shift from work to disability programs, that I  have actually been reporting on it for years, and I didn't even know it.
残疾项目就像一块海绵，吸纳了那些陷入绝望的人。这种情况在全国许多地方如此频繁地发生，从工作向残疾项目的转变如此普遍，以至于我报道它已经好几年了，甚至都没意识到。
A small town already struggling through financial troubles just found out a major employer is shutting down. Warehouses were closed. One of the largest sawmills in the state.
一个小镇已经在财务困境中苦苦挣扎，刚刚发现一家大型雇主正在倒闭。仓库关闭了。州里最大的锯木厂之一。
This is a familiar narrative, a small town or city loses its main industry. When the mill closed in Aberdeen in Washington state, I covered it. I stood in the dead mill with a bunch of laid off workers, memorializing the end of an era. An era in America where you could graduate high school, get a job at a mill, and live a good life.
这是一个熟悉的故事，一个小镇或城市失去了它的主要产业。当华盛顿州阿伯丁（Aberdeen）的木材厂关闭时，我报道过。我站在死寂的工厂里，和一群下岗工人一起，纪念一个时代的终结。一个在美国可以高中毕业、进工厂工作、过上好日子的时代。
We grew up together. We've gotten married. We've had children. We've raised families. Them were the best jobs on the harbor. When you had one of them jobs, you had a great job.
我们一起长大。我们结婚了。我们有了孩子。我们养家糊口。那些是港口最好的工作。当你拥有一份那种工作时，你就拥有一份好工作。
For NPR News, I'm Chana Joffe-Walt.
NPR新闻，我是查娜·乔菲-沃尔特。
And that was it. That was the end of the story. That is always the end of the story. I had no idea what would actually become of these guys, because I, like every other reporter, showed up at the worst possible time to answer that question. The exact moment no one knows what this new reality will look like.
就这样了。故事到此结束。故事总是这样结束的。我根本不知道这些人会变成什么样，因为我和其他记者一样，在回答那个问题的最糟糕的时机出现。在没人知道这个新现实会是什么样子的确切时刻。
So a couple weeks ago, I called some of the guys I met four years ago in Aberdeen.
所以几周前，我给四年前在阿伯丁认识的一些人打了电话。
OK, is that better?
好的，这样更好吗？
I can hear you, but not real well.
我能听到你，但听得不是很清楚。
Not well? OK, let me turn my volume up.
不清楚吗？好吧，让我调高音量。
Scott Birdsall told me after the mill closed, all the worker retraining agencies from the county came in. They set up a bunch of meetings, delivered a bunch of pep talks. Scott says he went to every one, even though they all basically had the same message.
斯科特·伯德萨尔（Scott Birdsall）告诉我，工厂倒闭后，县里所有的转岗机构都进来了。他们安排了一堆会议，发表了一堆励志演讲。斯科特说他参加了每一个，尽管他们的信息基本上都一样。
Oh, just there's programs available and schooling and stuff like that. Retraining programs and they could help you with resumes and things like that.
哦，只是有些项目、培训之类的。再就业培训项目，他们可以帮你处理简历之类的事情。
Scott was 56 at the time. The last time he set foot in a classroom was 1972. And he hated school. But the worker retraining people were encouraging a forestry degree. Scott had his doubts.
斯科特当时56岁。他最后一次踏入教室是1972年。他讨厌学校。但再就业人员鼓励他获得林业学位。斯科特有疑虑。
And then he went to yet another worker retraining meeting at a place called WorkSource. And right in the middle of a pep talk about resumes and the value of education, one the staff pulled him aside.
然后他去参加了另一个叫WorkSource的再就业会议。在关于简历和教育价值的励志演讲中间，一名工作人员把他拉到一边。
There was an older guy there that worked for WorkSource, and he just looked at me, and he goes Scott, I'm going to be honest with you. He goes, there's nobody going to hire you. He goes, we're just hiding you guys. That's all we're doing.
那里有一个老员工，他看着我说，斯科特，我跟你说实话。他说，没有人会雇佣你。他说，我们只是在“隐藏”你们这些人。这就是我们所做的一切。
What do you mean hiding you guys?
你所谓的“隐藏”是什么意思？
We're just keeping you, you know, out of the picture. And there's no place for you around here where you're going to get a job. Just draw your unemployment, and just suck all the benefits you can out of the system until everything's gone. And then you're on your own.
我们只是让你们保持在视野之外。在这附近没有地方你能找到工作。去领你的失业救济金吧，尽可能从这个系统中吸取所有福利，直到一切都完了。然后你就只能靠自己了。
Scott says it was the most real thing anyone had said in a while. After the mill closed, Scott had a heart attack. And he did try school for a while, hated it once again.
斯科特说，这是最近有人说过的最实在的话了。工厂倒闭后，斯科特心脏病发作了。他确实尝试了一段时间的学校，结果又一次讨厌它。
I thought well, you know, since I've had a bypass, maybe I can get on disability, and then I won't have to worry about this stuff anymore.
我想，既然我做过搭桥手术，也许我可以申请残疾补助，然后就不用再担心这些事了。
Scott was essentially taking the advice of the rogue staffer at the worker retraining office. He could have stayed in school until he was 60 in the hopes of getting a park ranger job, making half the salary he made at the mill. He made about $60,000 a year at the mill. Or, as he says, he could just accept that he was no longer useful to this economy. Didn't have the right education, right skills. He could just accept that and check out. Turns out, there is a way to do that.
斯科特本质上是采纳了再就业办公室那位特立独行的工作人员的建议。他本可以一直在学校待到60岁，希望得到一份公园管理员的工作，薪水只有他在厂里的一半。他在厂里一年大约挣6万美元。或者，正如他所说，他可以接受自己对这个经济不再有用。没有合适的教育，没有合适的技能。他可以接受这一切，然后退出。事实证明，有一种方法可以做到。
And then that's  how I wound up getting into the disability thing.
所以我就这样进入了“残疾”这件事。
And it wasn't just Scott. I talked to a bunch of mill guys who took this path. One who shattered the bone in his ankle and his leg, one with diabetes, another with a heart attack. When the mill shut down, they all went on disability. And they all, like Scott, would prefer to be at the mill. Scott  says if circumstances had been different, if the entire economy had not changed underneath his feet and the mill was still open, he'd be there.
不仅是斯科特。我和很多走这条路的工厂兄弟谈过。有人摔碎了踝骨和腿，有人患有糖尿病，有人心脏病发作。当工厂倒闭时，他们都申请了残疾补助。他们都像斯科特一样，更愿意待在工厂里。斯科特说，如果情况不同，如果整个经济没有在他的脚下改变，而且工厂还在营业，他会待在那里的。
I don't know what that one rogue staffer meant when he told Scott Birdsall they were trying to hide those  mill guys. But signing up for disability benefits is an excellent way to stay hidden. People on disability, the way the government counts you, you're not part of the labor force, meaning you're not counted in the unemployment figures.
我不知道那位特立独行的工作人员告诉斯科特他们试图“隐藏”那些工厂工人的时候是什么意思。但是申请残疾补助是保持“隐藏”的好方法。按照政府的统计方式，领残疾补助的人不属于劳动力范畴，这意味着你没有被计入失业数字中。
An economist, David Autor at MIT, told me, macroeconomically speaking, people on disability are invisible.
麻省理工学院的经济学家大卫·奥特（David Autor）告诉我，从宏观经济学角度来看，领取残疾补助的人是隐形的。
Well, that's kind of an ugly secret of the American labor market, that part of the reason our unemployment rates have been low until recently is that a lot of people who would have trouble finding jobs are on a different program. They're on the disability insurance program. And they don't show up in the labor force statistics. And so it artificially reduces the unemployment rate that we observe.
嗯，这是美国劳动力市场一个丑陋的秘密，我们失业率之所以能保持在低位，部分原因是许多难以找到工作的人在另一个项目里。他们在残疾保险项目中。他们没有出现在劳动力统计数据中。所以这人为地降低了我们观察到的失业率。
So you're saying we all already knew it was bad. It's actually worse than we think.
你是说我们都知道情况很糟。实际上比我们想象的还要糟。
It is. It's been worse than we thought for a long time. This has been going on pretty rapidly for now more than 20 years.
确实。很长一段时间以来都比我们想的要糟。这种情况已经以相当快的速度持续了20多年。
David Autor says disability has become a sort of de facto welfare for people without a lot of education or job skills. Except it is the worst kind of welfare program, because it includes one feature you never, ever want from your social safety net.
大卫·奥特说，残疾补助已经成为一种事实上的福利，专门提供给那些没有受过良好教育或职业技能的人。除了它是最糟糕的福利项目，因为它包含了一个你永远、永远都不希望从社会安全网中得到的功能。
Once people go in that direction, they're unlikely to come back.
一旦人们朝着那个方向走去，他们就不太可能回来了。
The problem with using our disability programs as a sort of quiet de facto welfare system is they're not designed to help people to deal with their disabilities, to get jobs, to make increasingly more money over a lifetime. They're not there to catch you when you fall down and help you back on your feet.
把残疾项目作为一种安静的“事实上的”福利体系的问题在于，它们不是为了帮助人们应对残疾、获得工作、在一生中赚越来越多的钱而设计的。它们不是在你跌倒时接住你并帮你重新站起来的。
Once a worker gets on disability, there are really only two ways out. You get old enough that at 65, 66-years-old, you move on to a different government program, Social Security for seniors, or you die. Those are the two ways people exit disability. Almost no one gets better. The benefits don't get you rehabilitative services or supportive technology. They just give you a monthly income.
一旦劳动者进入了残疾补助，实际上只有两条出路。你到了65或66岁，转入另一个政府项目，即老年社会保障，或者你去世。这就是人们退出残疾补助的两条途径。几乎没有人会好起来。这些补助不会提供康复服务或辅助技术。它们只是给你一份月收入。
And it's not a great income, about $13,000 a year. But if your alternative is a minimum wage job that will pay you $15,000 a year-- a job you may or may not be able to get, may or may not be able to keep, that probably won't be full time, and very likely will not include health insurance-- disability may be a better option.
这也不是一份丰厚的收入，大约一年13000美元。但如果你的替代选择是一份一年15000美元的最低工资工作——一份你可能得到也可能得不到、可能保得住也可能保不住的工作，而且可能不是全职，很可能不包含医疗保险——残疾补助可能是一个更好的选择。
Well let's just think about what that option means. You will not work. You will not interact with coworkers, get promoted, make more money, get whatever meaning people get from work. And assuming you rely only on those disability benefits, you will be poor for the rest of your life. That is signing up for disability. That's the deal. And it's a deal 14 million Americans have chosen for themselves.
好吧，让我们思考一下那个选择意味着什么。你不会工作。你不会与同事互动、晋升、赚更多钱、获得人们从工作中获得的任何意义。假设你只依靠那些残疾补助，你余生都会很贫穷。这就是申请残疾补助的代价。这就是交易。这是1400万美国人为自己做出的交易。
Chana Joffe-Walt. Coming up, we meet super nice, highly effective people who have one dream, and that is to get you-- yes, you-- onto disability. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特。接下来，我们将见到那些超级友好、非常高效的人，他们有一个梦想，那就是让你——没错，就是你——进入残疾补助。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Trends with Benefits. Why are so many people now ending up on disability? And it's hard to talk about all the money that the government pays to poor and disabled people without getting to a very basic question-- what should the government do for people who are not making it in this country, for the nation's most vulnerable people? We have argued about that question, answered that question in different ways at different times in our country's history.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是“福利趋势”。为什么现在有这么多人最终领上了残疾补助？如果不触及一个非常基本的问题，就很难谈论政府支付给贫困和残疾人的所有资金——政府应该为那些在这个国家无法生存的人，为国家最脆弱的人做些什么？在我们国家历史的不同时期，我们曾以不同的方式争论过这个问题，回答过这个问题。
For decades now, there have been some efforts to get people off of government checks. One of the biggest back in 1996, you may remember, President Bill Clinton signed legislation to quote, "end welfare as we know it." The idea was nudge people off of public assistance, give them job training. It has generally been seen as a big, big success, including by President Clinton. Here he is in 1998, just two years after it was passed.
几十年来，一直有一些努力让人们不再领取政府支票。其中最大的一次是在1996年，你可能记得，比尔·克林顿总统签署了立法，引用“终结我们所知的福利”。这个想法是推动人们摆脱公共援助，给他们职业培训。它普遍被视为一个巨大的、巨大的成功，包括克林顿总统本人。这是他在1998年，即法案通过两年后说的话。
We can be proud that after decades of finger pointing and failure, together we ended the old welfare system. And we're now replacing welfare checks with paychecks.
我们可以感到自豪的是，经过几十年的指责和失败，我们共同终结了旧的福利体系。我们现在正在用工资支票取代福利支票。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Last year, after a record four-year decline in welfare rolls, I challenged our nation to move two million more Americans off welfare by the year 2000. I'm pleased to report we have also met that goal, two full years ahead of schedule.
去年，在福利名单连续四年创纪录下降后，我向全国挑战，要在2000年前让另外200万美国人摆脱福利。我很高兴地报告，我们也提前整整两年实现了这一目标。
Now the premise of that, of course, was that there are jobs for all these welfare recipients to move into and get paychecks. But over the last 30 years, that has changed. The economy  has changed. Lots of good jobs have vanished. And government has not really kept up with all these changes. Has not figured out a way to address the needs of all of these workers.
当然，这一前提是所有这些福利领取者都有工作岗位可以进入并拿到工资支票。但在过去的30年里，情况发生了变化。经济发生了变化。许多好工作消失了。政府并没有真正跟上所有这些变化。没有找到一种方法来解决所有这些工人的需求。
And so in the place of the government doing stuff, others have stepped in, volunteers from the private sector, to see to the needs of those workers. Chana Joffe-Walt introduces us to some of these civic-minded Americans in this half of our show.
所以，在政府不再作为的地方，其他人介入了，来自私营部门的志愿者，来照顾那些工人的需求。在我们的节目下半部分，查娜·乔菲-沃尔特为我们介绍了这些具有公民意识的美国人。
In the absence of a government answer to an enormous American labor problem, what I'm going to go ahead and call the vast disability industrial complex has sprung up. Its leaders are these guys.
由于政府对一个巨大的美国劳动力问题没有答案，我称之为庞大的“残疾工业联合体”应运而生。它的领导者就是这些人。
Disabled and can't work? Get the money you deserve. Call Al Gemma at 1-800-677-9030. Al Gemma gets results.
残疾了不能工作？得到你应得的钱。致电阿尔·杰玛（Al Gemma）1-800-677-9030。阿尔·杰玛有结果。
Lawyers.
律师们。
Look, my law firm Brown and Crouppen has collected over a third of a billion dollars for injured people. Not million, billion. See, I fix problems.
看，我的律师事务所Brown and Crouppen已经为受伤的人追讨了超过三亿美元。不是百万，是亿。你看，我解决问题。
Disability lawyers offer to fix American's problems on billboards, taxis, and aggressively on television, often with props. Gavels slammed down to show they mean business, or even better, swords.
残疾律师在广告牌、出租车上，以及在电视上积极地提出解决美国人的问题，通常会带上道具。锤子砸下以显示他们是认真的，甚至更好，用剑。
[SOUND OF SWORD]
（剑的声音）
Has your disability claim been denied?
你的残疾索赔被拒绝了吗？
There are disability lawyers who golf, who dust their desk plants while making commercials, musical lawyers.
有会打高尔夫的残疾律师，有在做广告时给办公桌植物除尘的律师，还有会唱歌的律师。
[SINGING] Call the Davis Disability Group. Put us on your side.
（歌唱）致电戴维斯残疾小组。让我们站在你这边。
Lawyers who know how to listen.
懂得倾听的律师。
Call a lawyer who is also a psychologist. Call Dr. Bill LaTour. Disabled? Get the money you deserve.
找一位同时是心理学家的律师。致电比尔·拉图尔医生（Dr. Bill LaTour）。残疾了？得到你应得的钱。
And then there are the YouTube lawyers. One disability lawyer, one webcam. Usually the lawyer offers a handy anecdote that lets you know they're selling something you could buy.
还有YouTube律师。一位残疾律师，一个网络摄像头。律师通常提供一个便捷的轶事，让你知道他们在兜售一些你可以买到的东西。
I want to talk to you today about how disabled you have to be in order to get Social Security disability benefits. Well, the bottom line is you don't have to be an invalid. You don't have to be out on a stretcher. You don't have to be home wracked in pain to get Social Security disability benefits. Let me give you an example.
我今天想和你谈谈为了获得社会保障残疾福利，你必须达到什么程度的残疾。好吧，底线是你不必成为一个病残人。你不必躺在担架上。你不必在家中饱受疼痛折磨才能获得社会保障残疾福利。让我给你举个例子。
Almost every ad and YouTube tutorial makes sure to mention that the lawyers don't get paid unless you win. So let's talk about how the lawyers get paid for a second here. The economist, David Autor, was the first to explain this to me. If a person applies for disability, is denied, hires a lawyer, and then wins, he gets back pay for the time he waited for his hearing. Lawyers get a one-time fee, a portion of the back pay, up to 25%.
几乎每一个广告和YouTube教程都确保提及，如果不赢，律师就不会收费。所以让我们谈谈律师如何获得报酬。经济学家大卫·奥特是第一个向我解释这一点的人。如果一个人申请残疾，被拒绝，请了律师，然后赢了，他会得到等待听证期间的补发工资。律师会得到一次性费用，即补发工资的一部分，最高可达25%。
The money comes out of the disabled person's back pay. But the disabled person doesn't hand over a check to the lawyer, the government does.
这笔钱来自残疾人的补发工资。但残疾人不需要给律师开支票，政府会开。
The Social Security Administration makes that payment directly to the attorney, not to the individual.  So the individual gets their cut, the attorney gets their cut. So each year, the Social  Security Administration makes more than $1 billion in payments directly to attorneys that have prevailed against it in front of ALJs.
社会保障局直接向律师支付那笔款项，而不是给个人。所以个人拿到他们的份额，律师拿到他们的份额。因此，每年社会保障局向在行政法官（ALJ）面前战胜它的律师支付超过10亿美元的款项。
Wait, so the government employs lawyers to fight the government.
等等，所以政府雇佣律师来对抗政府？
No, no. It doesn't employ the lawyers. It just pays them. It just pays the ones who win.
不，不。它不雇佣律师。它只是付钱给他们。它只付钱给那些获胜的人。
It pays the lawyers that win suing the government.
它付钱给打赢官司起诉政府的律师。
Right, exactly. It pays the lawyers that defeat it.
对，没错。它付钱给击败它的律师。
Social Security set it up this way to encourage lawyers to represent poor clients. But I think it's safe to say the government did not expect that this financial incentive would lead lawyers to find people who had been denied disability four times, put them on television, and tell them and the viewing public--
社会保障局这样设置是为了鼓励律师代理贫困客户。但我认为可以肯定地说，政府没想到这种经济激励会导致律师去寻找那些被拒绝四次的人，把他们搬上电视，告诉他们和观众——
Don't give up. If you've applied and been denied, call attorney Ed Tend. He's local. He knows your doctors.
别放弃。如果你申请了但被拒绝，致电律师埃德·坦德（Ed Tend）。他是本地的。他了解你的医生。
Social Security denies a lot of people, at least the first time around. Only about a third of those who apply are awarded benefits, and the rest are denied. So more and more people see these ads and appeal the decisions.
社会保障局确实拒绝了很多人，至少在第一次申请时是这样。只有约三分之一的申请者获得福利，其余都被拒绝。所以越来越多的人看到这些广告并对决定提出上诉。
Not everyone appeals, a little more than half. And those who do have much better chances. Almost 2/3 of the time, usually with the help of representation, they win. This fact is new, the explosion of appeals and disability lawyers. And there is one firm that proudly takes credit for it, for transforming the way Americans win disability benefits.
并不是每个人都上诉，大概一半多一点。而那些上诉的人机会好得多。近三分之二的情况下，通常在代理人的帮助下，他们会获胜。这个事实是新的，上诉和残疾律师的爆发。有一家公司自豪地为此居功，因为它改变了美国人获得残疾福利的方式。
Nobody intimidates our clients, nobody. That's one reason we're America's most successful Social Security disability advocates.
没人能恐吓我们的客户，没人。这就是为什么我们是美国最成功的社会保障残疾倡导者。
America's most successful disability advocates are Binder & Binder.
美国最成功的残疾倡导者是Binder & Binder。
And we make you this very special promise.
我们向你做出这个非常特别的承诺。
We'll deal with the government. You have enough to worry about.
我们会处理政府的事情。你有足够多的事情要担心了。
Call us.
给我们打电话。
That guy making the promise is a cowboy-hatted Charles Binder, pointing straight into the camera. A man who has completely changed the game for disability lawyers.
那个做出承诺的人是戴着牛仔帽的查尔斯·宾德（Charles Binder），手指直指摄像机。一个完全改变了残疾律师游戏规则的人。
It's funny, when we started-- I don't think when we started, anybody else was advertising Social Security. Something, and this number you're going to be shocked by, about 90% of the people who apply for disability never got to a hearing. Because they would get denied once, and they'd get denied twice, and they'd say, well, you can't win this. And now the number of people who go to a hearing is like 95%. The people who apply who lose go onto a hearing, because they're well represented.
有趣的是，当我们开始时——我不认为当我们开始时，还有其他人做社会保障广告。关于这个数字你会感到震惊，大约90%申请残疾的人从未参加过听证会。因为他们会被拒绝一次，被拒绝两次，他们会说，好吧，这赢不了。现在去听证会的人数是95%。申请失败的人会去参加听证会，因为他们有很好的代理。
Binder's numbers are a bit high, but you get the picture. Things have really changed.
宾德的数字有点高，但你明白了。情况真的变了。
To some extent, I take credit for that. I've created some of the problems for the government, because so many people appeal. In the old days, they had many fewer people.
在某种程度上，我把功劳归于自己。我给政府制造了一些问题，因为很多人上诉。在过去，他们的申请人少得多。
When it comes to life accomplishments, it is unusual to find someone who can reasonably add "changed the US economy" to the list. Charles Binder arguably can. This is a man who is personally responsible for the transfer of billions of dollars of disability payments.
当谈到生活成就时，很少有人能合理地在名单上加上“改变了美国经济”。查尔斯·宾德可以说做到了。这是一个个人负责转移数十亿美元残疾赔偿金的人。
When he started in 1979, Binder and Binder represented less than 50 clients. Last year, 30,000-- 30,000 people who were denied disability appealed with the help of Charles Binder in one year. And for that work, the government wrote a check for $68.7  million.
1979年他刚开始时，Binder & Binder代理了不到50个客户。去年，30000人——30000名被拒绝残疾补助的人在查尔斯·宾德的帮助下在一年内上诉。为了这项工作，政府开出了一张6870万美元的支票。
The way Binder tells it, he is a guy helping desperate people get the support they deserve. He's a cowboy-hatted Lone Ranger fighting the good fight for the everyman. He apparently keeps a picture of the Lone Ranger on his  desk.
照宾德的话说，他是一个帮助绝望的人获得他们应得支持的人。他是一个戴着牛仔帽的“独行侠”，为普通人打好仗。他显然在桌子上放着一张独行侠的照片。
So you've got 30,000 people denied disability who are appealing to a judge, taking their case to the courts. And on the one side, the judge has this passionate persuasive lawyer making the case that his client is physically or emotionally incapable of working. And on the other side, who's on the other side? Nobody. Nobody, really. I couldn't believe this when I first heard it. David Autor, the economist, told me with disability cases, there is no person in the room making the government's case.
所以你有30000人被拒绝残疾补助，他们正在向法官上诉，将他们的案件诉诸法庭。一方面，法官有一位富有激情、口才说服力强的律师，辩称他的客户在身体或情绪上无法工作。而另一方面，谁在另一方面？没人。真的没人。我第一次听说时简直不敢相信。经济学家大卫·奥特告诉我，残疾案件中，房间里没有人为政府辩护。
You might imagine a courtroom where, on the one side, there's the claimant and their lawyer saying, my client needs these benefits. On the other side, there's the government attorney saying, ah no, well, we need to protect the public interest, and your client is not sufficiently deserving, and here's why I think that, and so on. But it actually doesn't work like that. Because the government is not represented. There is no government lawyer on the other side of the room.
你可以想象一个法庭，一边是索赔人和他们的律师说，我的客户需要这些福利。另一边是政府律师说，啊，不，好吧，我们需要保护公共利益，你的客户不够资格，这就是我这么认为的原因等等。但实际情况并不是这样。因为政府没有代表。房间对面没有政府律师。
The Social Security Administration says disability hearings were never meant to be adversarial. In these courtrooms, the judges are employees of Social Security. So they have a dual role-- to represent the government and to make a fair and objective determination.
社会保障局表示，残疾听证会从来不是为了对抗性的。在这些法庭上，法官是社会保障局的雇员。所以他们扮演着双重角色——代表政府并做出公平客观的判定。
But when you talk to these representatives of the government, who also happen to be fair and objective judges, they will tell you this dual role can be uncomfortable, difficult. One judge, Judge Randy Frye in North Carolina, who hears disability cases told me he will often find himself glancing to where he imagines there should be another chair, like in any normal courtroom.
但当你与这些政府代表（碰巧也是公平客观的法官）交谈时，他们会告诉你这种双重角色可能令人不舒服、困难。一位在北卡罗来纳州审理残疾案件的兰迪·弗莱法官（Judge Randy Frye）告诉我，他经常发现自己看向他想象中应该有另一把椅子的地方，就像在任何普通法庭一样。
And there are always moments where you are concerned that maybe you missed something.
总有一些时刻你担心也许你错过了什么。
And you wish you could turn to that chair?
你希望你能转向那把椅子？
Absolutely. You would turn to the chair and say, counsel, I'm having trouble with this issue. Why does the government think this case should not be reversed?
绝对。你会转向椅子说，顾问，我在这个问题上有麻烦。为什么政府认为这个案件不应该被驳回？
If someone is awarded disability benefits, that person will receive an average of $250,000 to $350,000 from the government in benefits and health care over a lifetime. If you sued a company for that amount of money, even a tiny company, they would bring a lawyer with them to court. Not so with the government's disability program. The government is not even in the room.
如果一个人被授予残疾福利，那个人一生中将从政府那里平均获得25万美元到35万美元的福利和医疗保健。如果你因为那笔钱起诉一家公司，即使是一家小公司，他们也会带一位律师上法庭。政府的残疾项目则不然。政府甚至不在房间里。
So lawyers are making money moving people onto disability. No big surprise there. They are, you know, lawyers. But there is another group of people who are quietly doing this too. And who they're working for I found very surprising.
所以律师通过让人们进入残疾补助来赚钱。这没啥大惊小怪的。他们是，你知道，律师。但还有另一群人也在悄悄地做这件事。而且我发现他们为谁工作非常令人惊讶。
I want to introduce you, I want to take you inside an entire office building of these people. But first  I have to explain why they exist. It has a lot to do with this guy you heard from before.
我想把你介绍一下，我想带你走进一整栋这些人的办公楼。但首先我必须解释他们为什么存在。这与你之前听到的这个家伙有很大关系。
We can be proud that after decades of finger pointing and failure, together we ended the old welfare system. And we're now replacing welfare checks with paychecks.
我们可以感到自豪的是，经过几十年的指责和失败，我们共同终结了旧的福利体系。我们现在正在用工资支票取代福利支票。
President Bill Clinton turned welfare checks into paychecks with the help of states. Mary Daly, an economist at the San Francisco Federal Reserve, says after the 1996 reforms, the government said states had to pay a much larger share of the cost of welfare.
比尔·克林顿总统在各州的帮助下，将福利支票变成了工资支票。旧金山联邦储备银行的经济学家玛丽·戴利（Mary Daly）表示，1996年改革后，政府表示各州必须承担更大比例的福利成本。
So states had every incentive to try to get their welfare caseloads down.
所以各州都有充分的动力试图压低他们的福利个案数。
Hopefully by getting people jobs. Welfare rolls were cut in half in just a few years. And so we all assumed that's what was happening. Mary Daly wondered if there wasn't a different story.
希望通过让人找到工作来实现。福利名单在短短几年内减少了一半。所以我们都以为这就是正在发生的事情。玛丽·戴利想知道是否有不同的故事。
States wanted to get people off the rolls and save money. If they couldn't get them jobs, there was another option-- disability. Disability is a federal program, so it's paid for by the federal government. In other words, if states could get people on to disability--
各州想让人离开名单并省钱。如果他们找不到工作，还有另一个选择——残疾补助。残疾补助是一个联邦项目，所以它由联邦政府支付。换句话说，如果各州能让人进入残疾补助——
They don't have to pay for them.
他们就不必为他们付费。
But they do have to pay for people who are on welfare.
但他们确实必须为那些领取福利的人付费。
They do. And they don't have to pay for disability programs.
他们确实得付。而且他们不必为残疾项目付费。
Mary Daly became more and more convinced this was happening. She published papers. In 2011, she coauthored a book about it. But it was just a theory.
玛丽·戴利越来越确信这就是正在发生的事情。她发表了论文。2011年，她合著了一本关于此的书。但这只是一个理论。
So I have my models and my theories, and I can write down what economists think. But you're never sure. You look for the empirical data, but you're never sure that what your models say actually happens.
所以我有了模型和理论，我可以写下经济学家们的想法。但你永远不确定。你寻找经验数据，但你永远不确定你的模型所说的真的发生了。
Until Mary Daly was very, very sure, thanks to one chance encounter she had in Los Angeles. She was at a conference.
直到玛丽·戴利非常、非常确定，多亏了她在洛杉矶的一次偶然相遇。她在参加一个会议。
It was a big hotel. And this was like the second floor ballroom type of thing, where they put the coffee break.
那是一家大酒店。这是一个二楼宴会厅类型的地方，他们设置了茶歇。
Mary spotted a young guy in the corner looking a little nervous.
玛丽发现一个年轻人站在角落里看起来有点紧张。
He was wearing a suit. He was probably in his late 20s. Yeah, and I just tried to be social. And I said, so what do you do? He asked me what I  did.  I told him what I was there to do and what kind of research I did. And he said, oh, I work for a private sector company. And our job is to sell services to states.
他穿着西装。他可能快30岁了。是的，我只是尝试社交。我说，你是做什么的？他问我做什么。我告诉了他我来这里做什么以及我做了什么研究。他说，哦，我为一家私营部门公司工作。我们的工作是向各州销售服务。
Specifically, this man told Mary states were hiring his company to help them comb through their welfare rolls and identify people who could qualify for disability.
具体来说，这个人告诉玛丽，各州正在雇用他的公司来帮助他们梳理福利名单，并找出有资格领取残疾补助的人。
And that they were now helping states move people onto the federal program. So I said, really? We have this written in our book that this would likely happen.
而且他们现在正在帮助各州将人们转移到联邦项目中。我说，真的吗？我们的书里写着这很可能会发生。
You're like, my model predicts that this is going to happen.
你就像说，我的模型预测这会发生。
Yeah, I  said this is what we wrote in our book. We have a diagram that suggests this will happen. But you're telling me it actually is happening. And he said, yes. Maybe one of the biggest regrets I have is that I was so surprised to run into him and to learn this that I didn't question him more.
是的，我说这是我们在书里写的。我们有一张图表表明这会发生。但你是在告诉我它真的在发生。他说，是的。我最大的遗憾之一就是我当时太惊讶遇到他并了解到这一点，我没能再多问他一些。
No, it was a  good conference. I believe I did speak with her outside of one of the sessions that had just ended. We were kind of out in the coffee area there  and talking.
不，那是一个很好的会议。我相信我在其中一场刚结束的会议外和她谈过。我们当时在咖啡区聊天。
This is Pat Coakley. He works for a company called Public Consulting Group. He's the head of PCG's Social Security Advocacy management team, a subgroup of PCG that welfare reform created. PCG has competitors, but they're the biggest player offering welfare to disability services. And Pat told me business is going well. They have 17 contracts with states and counties around the country. He just signed up a new one, Missouri.
这是帕特·科克利（Pat Coakley）。他在一家名为公共咨询集团（Public Consulting Group，简称PCG）的公司工作。他是PCG社会保障倡导管理团队的负责人，这是福利改革所创建的PCG的一个子群。PCG有竞争对手，但他们是提供“福利转残疾”服务的最大玩家。帕特告诉我生意进展顺利。他们在全国各地的州和县有17个合同。他刚刚签署了一个新的，密苏里州。
So what we're offering is to work to identify those folks who have the highest likelihood of meeting disability criteria. We will screen through their case loads. We will look to identify these individuals. It's also removing that person from the state welfare program.
所以我们提供的是致力于识别那些最有可能满足残疾标准的民众。我们将筛选他们的个案。我们将寻找识别这些个人。这也将那个人从州福利项目中移除。
And Pat says it's a win-win. For the people on welfare, disability is a much better deal. In some states, you can make four times as much on that program than on welfare.
帕特说这是双赢。对于领取福利的人来说，残疾补助是一个更好的交易。在一些州，你在那个项目上赚的钱可能是福利的四倍。
So the first step is identifying people who might qualify. And Pat says that's actually the least time consuming part of their work,. What takes a really long time is what happens next.
所以第一步是识别可能符合条件的人。帕特说那实际上是他们工作中耗时最少的部分。真正花费很长时间的是接下来发生的事情。
This is Cathy with Public Consulting Group.
这是PCG的凯西（Cathy）。
How are you?
你好吗？
Good.  How are you?
好，你呢？
The PCG office is in eastern Washington state. It's basically a call center, head-setted women in cubicles surrounded by pictures of their kids in Hawaii, making calls all day long to potentially disabled Americans. Trying to help them to discover and document their disabilities.
PCG的办公室位于华盛顿州东部。它基本上是一个呼叫中心，戴着耳机的女性坐在隔间里，被她们孩子在夏威夷的照片包围着，整天给可能残疾的美国人打电话。试图帮助他们发现并记录他们的残疾。
All right, moving on, the high blood pressure, how long have  you been taking medications for that? And the sleep apnea since about 2008. OK, I'm going to change that date for you, OK? OK, that's perfect. Can you think of anything else that has been bothering you and disabling you and preventing you from working?
好的，继续，高血压，你吃药多久了？还有2008年左右的睡眠呼吸暂停。好的，我要帮你改一下那个日期，好吗？好的，太完美了。你能想到还有什么在困扰你、让你残疾并阻止你工作吗？
The PCG agents will help the potentially disabled fill out the disability application over the phone. And by help, I mean the agents actually do the filling out. When the potentially disabled don't have the right medical documentation to prove a disability, the agents at PCG will help them get it. They will call doctor's offices, x-ray centers, get records faxed.
PCG代理人将在电话中帮助那些可能残疾的人填写残疾申请。所谓“帮助”，我的意思是代理人实际上是在替他们填写。当那些可能残疾的人没有合适的医疗记录来证明残疾时，PCG的代理人会帮他们获取。他们会给医生办公室、X光中心打电话，让记录传真过来。
Sure, and that's fine. We can actually-- do have an address to Quest Diagnostics? Uh huh. I can actually try to look that up for you, if you'd like for me to.
当然，没问题。我们实际上可以——有Quest Diagnostics的地址吗？嗯哼。如果你愿意的话，我实际上可以帮你查一下。
If the right medical records do not exist, PCG will set up doctor's appointments and call applicants the day before to remind them of those appointments.
如果没有合适的医疗记录，PCG会安排医生预约，并在前一天给申请人打电话提醒他们预约。
I just wanted to confirm with you that Zachary will be at that appointment. And the address, I'll give you the address when you're ready.
我只是想和你确认一下扎卡里（Zachary）会参加那个预约。至于地址，准备好了我给你地址。
This is customer service in its most aggressive form. If the agents at airlines and health insurance companies worked like PCG agents, the world would be a much happier place.
这是最激进形式的客户服务。如果航空公司和健康保险公司的代理人能像PCG代理人那样工作，世界会变得更加快乐。
These people are thorough. And once you're in their sights, they're on your side. They want you to get onto disability. And there is one simple reason for that. At the end of the PCG tour, I asked manager Leslie Jose--
这些人很彻底。一旦你进入了他们的视野，他们就站在你这边。他们希望你进入残疾补助。原因很简单。在PCG参观结束时，我问经理莱斯利·何塞（Leslie Jose）——
And how do you get paid?
你们是怎么拿报酬的？
We get paid by-- our client would be like the state or the county. And so we'll get paid when we're successful with a person's claim.
我们的客户是像州或县那样的单位，所以当我们在一个人的索赔中取得成功时，我们就会获得报酬。
Per person.
按人头？
按人头。
So for every person that you get onto disability.
所以每获得一个残疾补助的人。
For   every file we get on, then we would submit an invoice for that person.
我们接手的每一个案子，如果成功，我们就会提交一份关于那个人的发票。
In PCG's bid for the Missouri contract, it asked for $2,300 a person. Every time one of these agents succeed in winning a client disability, the state will write PCG a check. If it's successful, PCG estimates it'll save Missouri about $80 million with all the people it will be getting onto disability and off welfare. And PCG is used to being successful.
在PCG竞标密苏里州合同中，它要求每人2300美元。每当这些代理人成功为客户赢取残疾补助时，州政府就会给PCG开一张支票。如果成功，PCG估计这将为密苏里州节省约8000万美元。PCG习惯于成功。
How often do you win?
你们赢的频率是多少？
We have a 70% to 75%.
我们有70%到75%。
So 70% to 75% of the applications that you file win awards.
所以你们提交的申请中有70%到75%获批。
Are allowed at the initial level, yep.
在初始阶段被允许，是的。
70% to 75% percent success rate, that is basically unheard of. Again, without PCG, your chances of winning disability on first application are about 35%. But with PCG, you take some phone calls, maybe go to the doctor, and more likely than not, you win.
70%到75%的成功率，这简直是闻所未闻。同样，没有PCG，你首次申请获批残疾补助的机会大约是35%。但有了PCG，你打几个电话，也许去看个医生，多半情况下，你会赢。
Yeah, so the people are put into benefits. And they'll receive their Social Security disability income.
是的，所以人们被纳入福利体系。他们将获得社会保障残疾收入。
So you get people onto disability.
所以你让人们进入残疾补助。
We do. We're pretty proud of the work our staff are able to do.
我们做到了。我们为我们的员工所能做的工作感到相当自豪。
There was one line in the PCG contract with Missouri that stood out to me. PCG requests a fee of $1,745 for each successful foster child SSI application. What that means is if PCG gets foster kids on disability, the program called SSI, it gets paid for that too. Kids.
在PCG与密苏里州的合同中，有一行字引起了我的注意。PCG要求每份成功的寄养儿童SSI申请费用为1745美元。这意味着如果PCG让寄养儿童进入残疾项目（称为SSI），它也会因此获得报酬。孩子。
I heard this in Hale County that there were lots of kids on disability. I heard, actually, what you want is a kid who can pull a check. Many people mentioned this to me. And I basically ignored it. It seemed like one of those things that maybe happened once or twice, got written up in the paper, and became conversational fact among neighbors.
我在海尔县听说有很多孩子领残疾补助。我听说，实际上，你想要的是一个能拿支票的孩子。许多人对我提到这一点。我基本上忽略了它。这似乎是那种可能发生过一两次、上了报纸、变成邻居间谈资的事。
But I did look at the numbers. And the number of kids on Supplemental Security Income, SSI, for poor disabled children and adults, the number of kids is almost five times greater than it was 25 years ago. It's true. Yet another rapidly growing group of disabled Americans, children.
但我确实看了数据。领取补充保障收入（SSI）的贫困残疾儿童和成人的儿童数量，几乎是25年前的五倍。这是事实。又一个快速增长的残疾美国人群体：儿童。
Hi. Hi. What's your name?
嗨。嗨。你叫什么名字？
Jaleel.
杰里尔（Jaleel）。
Jaleel, how are you doing?
杰里尔，你好吗？
Jaleel Johnson [INAUDIBLE].
杰里尔·约翰逊（名字听不清）。
Jaleel is gap-toothed, 10, and vibrating with enthusiasm. He's excited to talk to someone new. Excited to show  me his map of his neighborhood in the Bronx. Just basically psyched about everything. Even things that aren't easy for Jaleel are exciting. He has a learning disability. But the way he talks about school--
杰里尔牙齿有缝，10岁，浑身充满热情。他很高兴能和新人交谈。很高兴向我展示他的布朗克斯社区地图。基本上对一切都非常兴奋。即使对杰里尔来说不容易的事情也很令人兴奋。他有学习障碍。但他谈论学校的方式——
My favorite periods is math and science and art and lunch and recess and snack and [INAUDIBLE] and ELA and social studies and writing are my fav--
我最喜欢的课是数学、科学、美术、午餐、课间休息、零食、（听不清）和ELA（英语语言艺术）、社会研究和写作是我最——
That sounds like everything.
听起来像所有课。
--are my favorite periods. I like school. School my favorite thing to go to.
——是我最喜欢的课。我喜欢学校。学校是我最喜欢去的地方。
Jaleel's mom gets about $700 a month for his disability. And the idea with the program is if you have a kid with a disability, you may have to work less to help that child out. That child's probably likely to be more expensive.
杰里尔的妈妈每月为他的残疾领取约700美元。这个项目的初衷是如果你有一个残疾孩子，你可能需要减少工作来帮助那个孩子。那个孩子可能更需要花钱。
When you're an adult applying for disability, you have to prove you can't function in a work-like setting. But when you're a kid, a disability can be anything that prevents you from progressing in school. And in the last two decades, there's been an explosion of kids on disability for mental or intellectual issues. It's now 2/3 of the kids on the program.
当你是一个申请残疾的成年人时，你必须证明你无法在类似工作的环境中运作。但当你是个孩子时，残疾可以是任何阻止你在学校进步的事物。在过去二十年里，患有精神或智力问题的残疾儿童数量激增。现在占了该项目中儿童的三分之二。
Jaleel is a kid you can imagine doing very well for himself. He is delayed. But given the right circumstances and support, it's easy to see that over the course of his schooling, Jaleel could catch up. School's his favorite thing to go to.
杰里尔是一个你能想象会很有出息的孩子。他发育迟缓。但给予适当的环境和支持，很容易看出在学习过程中，杰里尔是可以赶上的。学校是他最喜欢去的地方。
So let's imagine that happens. Jaleel does well in school, overcomes some of his disabilities, and he doesn't need the disability program anymore. That would obviously be great for every one, except it would also threaten Jaleel's family's livelihood. Because Jaleel's family, like a lot of kids on disability, survives off that check. Here's his mom, Nujima King. She's got two other kids, and she's not working.
那么让我们想象一下如果那发生了。杰里尔在学校表现出色，克服了一些残疾，他不再需要残疾项目了。这对每个人来说显然都很棒，但这也威胁到了杰里尔一家的生计。因为杰里尔一家，像很多领残疾补助的孩子一样，靠那张支票生存。这是他的妈妈，努吉玛·金（Nujima King）。她还有另外两个孩子，而且她没有工作。
Right now, the money that I'm receiving for him, it's extremely helpful.
目前，我收到的关于他的钱，非常有帮助。
So you don't have any other income other than the disability right now?
所以你除了残疾补助外，现在没有其他收入来源？
Just disability and a little bit of savings.
只有残疾补助和一点存款。
Nujima wants Jaleel to do well in school. That's absolutely clear. It is also true that Nujima's income depends on Jaleel struggling to do well in school. Depends on her kid continuing to be labeled disabled.
努吉玛希望杰里尔在学校表现出色。这绝对清楚。同样真实的是，努吉玛的收入取决于杰里尔在学校表现不佳。取决于她的孩子继续被贴上残疾的标签。
There are lots and lots of poor families in exactly this same impossible situation. I talked to mothers who seem to find themselves advocating something that seems completely counter-intuitive for any parent. Like a woman named Darinda   Cruise. Cruise I met in Greensboro, Alabama. Darinda has told her 18-year-old son not to work, because it'll get in the way of a disability check.
有很多很多贫困家庭处于这种完全无法实现的困境中。我采访过一些母亲，她们似乎发现自己正在提倡一些对任何父母来说完全反直觉的事情。比如我在阿拉巴马州格林斯伯勒遇到的一个叫达琳达·克鲁斯（Darinda Cruise）的女人。达琳达告诉她18岁的儿子不要工作，因为这会妨碍残疾支票。
And he said he really want to work. He tell me every day he want  to go to work.
他说他真的想工作。他每天都告诉我他想去工作。
But you don't want that. You want him to not mess up the disability application.
但你不想那样。你想让他别搞砸了残疾申请。
Yeah. Not right now.
是的。不是现在。
Parents get their kids on the program when they're under 18. And I guess it shouldn't be surprising, although I was pretty surprised by this-- 2/3 of them stay on disability when they become adults. They stay on a program that penalizes you if you start to do well in school or if you start to work as a grown up.
父母在孩子18岁以下时让他们进入该项目。我想这不应该令人惊讶，尽管我对此感到非常惊讶——他们中有三分之二在成年后仍然留在残疾项目里。他们留在了一个如果你在学校开始表现出色，或者如果你作为一个成年人开始工作就会惩罚你的项目中。
I'm kind of scared to work.
我有点害怕工作。
You're scared to work.
你害怕工作。
Yeah, because if I work, they'll go down on my  check.
是的，因为如果我工作，他们就会减少我的支票。
Talia  McFadden is 27-years-old. She's been on the disability program most of her life. She suffers from anxiety and depression. When she was 17, she tried to kill herself. The one time Talia did have a very part time job tutoring, Social Security saw she was making some income, so they reduced her check. Talia freaked out when this happened. She quit her job.
塔莉亚·麦克法登（Talia McFadden）27岁。她一生大部分时间都在领残疾补助。她患有焦虑和抑郁症。17岁时，她试图自杀。塔莉亚唯一一次有一份非常兼职的辅导工作时，社保局看到她在赚取一些收入，所以他们减少了她的支票。塔莉亚在发生这种情况时崩溃了。她辞去了工作。
She says her symptoms come and go, and she's just not confident she could hold down a full time job. So she doesn't want to do anything that can threaten a dependable, secure monthly check. That is incredibly valuable to her. Although, when she talks about her experience working as a tutor, sounds like that was pretty valuable too.
她说她的症状时好时坏，她只是不自信能保住一份全职工作。所以她不想做任何可能威胁到那份可靠、安全的月支票的事情。这对她来说非常有价值。尽管，当她谈论她做辅导员的经历时，听起来那份工作也非常有价值。
Most of my students said, I trust you. And I felt like-- I felt appreciated, you know. Sometimes the parents would say that the kid wouldn't stop talking about me.
我的大多数学生说，我相信你。我觉得——我觉得自己被赏识了，你知道。有时家长会说孩子不停地谈论我。
So that must have been hard to give that up.
所以放弃那份工作一定很难。
Yeah. Because it kind of gave me a sense of wanting to be and wanting to live.
是的。因为它给了我一种想要存在和想要活着的意义。
It gave you a sense of wanting to be and wanting to live?
它给了你一种想要存在和想要活着的意义？
Yeah, because I just feel like I don't belong. Like I'm not helping to make things better.
是的，因为我只是觉得自己不属于这里。我不觉得自己在帮助让事情变得更好。
The idea that we, as a society, should offer support to disabled children living in poverty, I haven't taken a survey or anything, but I'm guessing a large majority of Americans would be in favor of that in some form. We'd have a hard time agreeing exactly how we want to offer support. But I think there are some basic things we all agree on. Kids should be encouraged to go to school. Kids should want to do well in school. Parents should want their kids to do well in school. Kids should be confident their parents can provide for them, regardless of how they do in school. And the goal should always be for children to become more and more independent as they grow older, and, if possible, support themselves, somewhere around the age of 18.
我们作为一个社会应该为贫困的残疾儿童提供支持的想法，我没有做过调查，但我猜绝大多数美国人会以某种形式支持这一点。我们很难就我们想要如何提供支持达成一致。但我认为我们都同意一些基本点：应该鼓励孩子上学。孩子应该想要在学校表现出色。父母应该希望他们的孩子在学校表现出色。孩子应该有信心，无论他们在学校表现如何，他们的父母都能供养他们。目标应该始终是让孩子在长大后变得越来越独立，如果可能的话，在18岁左右能够自食其力。
This program stands in opposition to every one of these aims.
这个项目违背了所有这些目标。
So somewhere around 30 years ago, the economy started changing in some important ways. There are now millions of Americans who do not have the education or the skills for the current economy. And this does not seem temporary.
所以大约30年前，经济开始在一些重要方面发生变化。现在有数百万美国人没有适应当前经济的教育或技能。这似乎不是暂时的。
Politicians certainly pay lip service to this problem during election cycles and such. But American leaders have not sat down and said, look, things have fundamentally changed. What are we going to do for these people? We need a plan.
政客们在竞选周期中肯定会对这个问题进行口头上的支持。但美国领导人并没有坐下来讨论说：看，事情已经从根本上改变了。我们要为这些人做些什么？我们需要一个计划。
In the meantime, the disability programs have become the default plan. Programs that, along with the associated health care, cost about $260 billion a year. And I know this is obvious, but a quarter trillion dollars? That's a lot of money. That's eight times more than we spend on welfare. In fact, it is more than we spend on welfare, food stamps, the school lunch program, and subsidized housing combined. A lot more.
与此同时，残疾项目成了默认计划。这些项目连同相关的医疗保健，每年花费约2600亿美元。我知道这很明显，但四分之一万亿美元？那是一大笔钱。那是我们花在福利上资金的八倍。事实上，它比我们花在福利、食品券、学校午餐计划和补贴住房上的总和还要多。多得多。
Think for a minute of what we could do with a quarter trillion dollars. We could decide what we want is to expand welfare payments or food stamps. We could decide that the best plan is just to hand out cash to every out of work American. Or we could decide not to spend the money. Let everybody pay less in taxes. There are options. We just never made a decision.
花一分钟想想我们能用这四分之一万亿美元做什么。我们可以决定我们想要的是扩大福利支付或食品券。我们可以决定最好的计划就是给每个失业的美国人发放现金。或者我们可以决定不花这笔钱。让每个人少交税。有很多选择。我们只是从未做出决定。
Chana Joffe-Walt. She's with Planet Money, which is a co-production of our program and NPR News. At the Planet Money website, you can see some really startling graphs and charts that tell this story in a way that you really can't tell a story on the radio. Seriously, some of these are kind of amazing. That is at planetmoney.com.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特。她是Planet Money的成员，这是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。在Planet Money网站上，你可以看到一些非常惊人的图表和数据，它们以一种你在广播里讲故事无法呈现的方式讲述了这个故事。说真的，其中一些令人惊叹。网址是planetmoney.com。
Our program today was produced by Alex Blumberg and our senior producer, Julie Snyder with Ben Calhoun, Sara Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Production help from [INAUDIBLE]. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddes.
我们今天的节目由亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）制作，我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），参与制作的还有本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sara Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。制作帮助来自（听不清）。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。伊莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddes）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. I don't know. Sitting at a computer all day, I've been having this ache in my lower back. And he and I were talking about it in the break room. And then Torey just burst into song.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）负责。我不知道。整天坐在电脑前，我的下背部一直很痛。休息室里我和他谈起过。然后托里突然唱了起来。
[SINGING]  Call the Davis Disability Group. Put us on your side.
（歌唱）致电戴维斯残疾小组。让我们站在你这边。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。